DISTANCE HERSELF FROM HER PAST.
>> Laura: THANKS SO MUCH,
TRACE.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS THAT
LATEST TOSS-UP IS A WOMAN VYING
TO BECOME THE NEXT SENATOR.
IT'S MARTHA McSALLY FROM
ARIZONA.
LET'S START WITH IMMIGRATION.
WE JUST COMPLETED A FOCUS GROUP,
SO IMPORTANT FOR THE VOTERS OF
THE STATE.
HOW IS YOUR VIEW ON IMMIGRATION
DIFFERENT FROM YOUR OPPONENTS?
>> IT'S LIKE NIGHT AND IT DAY.
I CHAIR AT THE BORDER SECURITY
DISTRICT AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND I'M WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO MAKE SURE WE
BUILT A WALL, SECURE THE BORDER,
CLOSE THESE CRAZY LOOPHOLES THAT
ARE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF EVERY
DAY, AND MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY
THAT IS PROTECTING AMERICANS.
MY OPPONENT WAS ACTUALLY AN
ACTIVIST HELPING PEOPLE CROSS
ILLEGALLY IN HER PAST AND EVEN
THOUGH SHE HAS HAD AN AMAZING
POLITICAL MAKEOVERS, SHE HAS
VOTED TO SUPPORT SANCTUARY
CITIES.
AN IMPORTANT VOTE THAT'S
MEANINGFUL IN ARIZONA IS SHE
VOTED AGAINST GRANT'S LAW, NAMED
AFTER GRANT RUNNING BACK.
IN THE END ANGEL FAMILIES HAVE
ENDORSED ME AND SHE REFUSED TO
MEET WITH THEM.
GRANT WAS SHOT POINT BLANK BY
SOMEONE WHO SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE
BEEN HERE.
SHE REFUSED TO VOTE YES ON THIS,
AND SHE IS OUT OF TOUCH.
>> I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR
YOU BECAUSE SHE'S BASICALLY
SAYING I'M JUST AS GOOD AS
MARTHA McSALLY ON ISSUES LIKE
SENDING TROOPS TO THE BORDER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT'S NOT NEW FOR US TO HAVE
MILITARY DEPLOYMENT TO THE VOTE
VOTER, TO PROVIDE SUPPORT ROLES
OR CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS DOWN THERE.
WISH THEM WELL AND TELL THEM TO
STAY HYDRATED.
>> Laura: GET REAL.
SHE HAS NO IDEA WHAT SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT ENERGIES IN THE
WITNESS PROTECTION PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF BORDER SECURITY
IS SO IMPORTANT TO ALL
ARIZONANS.
THERE ARE SOME WHO CARE ABOUT
SAFETY AND SECURITY,
INDEPENDENCE AND REPUBLICANS.
SHE IS EXTREME ON THIS ISSUE AND
I TOTALLY WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SENDING OUR
TROOPS IN A SUPPORT ROLE TO
SECURE OUR BORDER.
THEY SUPPORT NATURAL DISASTERS,
THIS IS A DISASTER GOING ON IN
OUR BORDER.
STAY HYDRATED, RIGHT?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
I KNOW THEY WILL DO A GREAT JOB.
I SERVED IN THE MILITARY AND
THEY ARE SERVING AND
SACRIFICING.
BORDER SECURITY IS NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> Laura: SOME OF OUR FOCUS
GROUPS THAT WE JUST DID SAY IT'S
A BIG POLITICAL STUNT.
>> WE HAVE -- I REPRESENT
RANCHERS ON THE BORDER AND THEY
HAVE ENDORSED ME AND SO HAVE THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS
REPRESENTING 15,000 AGENTS.
THEY KNOW THE DANGEROUS
ACTIVITIES HAPPENING EVERY
SINGLE DAY ON THE BORDER.
>> Laura: BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP, AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ARIZONA HOSPITALS ARE AFFECTED
BY THIS.
WOMEN, AND HAVE THEIR CHILDREN,
AUTOMATIC PASSPORT.
>> THEN WE SEE THE CHINESE
COMING OVER BECAUSE THERE'S A
WHOLE FRAUDULENT WAY TO DO THAT.
I APPRECIATE THE PRESIDENT
BRINGING THIS UP, IF WE ACTUALLY
SECURE OUR BORDER AND CRACKDOWN
ON ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND CLOSE
THESE LOOPHOLES, WE WOULDN'T
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
HE'S HIGHLIGHTING THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN ABUSED -- >> IS A 14TH
AMENDMENT COVERED?
>> I'M NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
EXPERT BUT I THINK WE CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES WE WOULD STOP IT FROM
HAPPENING.
>> IT'S -- SIX KIDS, AND A
NUMBER OF HONDURAN NATIONALS
SAYING WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
IN PART, MENTIONING OUR SHOW,
THE LEGAL PROBLEM WITH THE TERMS
PLAN TO STOP CARAVANS OF PERSONS
FROM ENTERING THE COUNTRY THAT
SEEK ASYLUM, AND GOES ON TO SAY
THAT TRUNK AND NOT STOP THEM
FROM LEGALLY DOING SO NOR CAN
THE MILITARY OR ANYONE.
>> YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF PEOPLE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
WEAKNESSES IN LAWS THAT WE IN
CONGRESS NEED TO FIX.
MY BILL, WHICH YOU ALSO
SUPPORTED, THE GOODLATTE BILL,
WE WORK HARD TO CLOSE THESE
LOOPHOLES TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE COULDN'T SHOW UP AND
DEMAND THEIR WAY INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS IS HAPPENING EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN ARIZONA.
HUNDREDS OF MANY CARAVANS ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO SUE
THE PRESIDENT?
WE THIS HAS TO STOP.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE
SCREEN PARTY KOOK ENDORSING
KYRSTEN SINEMA?
>> SHE IS A GREEN PARTY ACTIVIS
ACTIVIST, AND IT'S ACTUALLY I
THINK A COMPLETION OF HER BEING
IDENTIFIED FOR WHO SHE REALLY I
IS.
ANGELA GREENE, THE GREEN PARTY
CANDIDATE, A MYSTERY TO HERSELF
AS A LIBERAL.
THE FACT THAT SHE IS GETTING
BEHIND KYRSTEN SINEMA HOPEFULLY
WILL HAVE PEOPLE WAKE UP AND
REALIZED THAT SHE'S NOT A
MODERATE.
SHE IS AN EXTREME LIBERAL, OUT
OF THE MAINSTREAM AND THIS JUST
BRINGS IT BACK FULL-CIRCLE OF
WHERE HER ROOTS ARE.
>> Laura: WHY IS THIS RACE SO
CLOSE?
>> MONEY.
THEY HAVE POURED TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO PRESENT
THIS IMAGE TO THE ARIZONA VOTERS
THAT SHE'S ACTUALLY RIGHT OF
CENTER.
IT'S NOT TRUE, IT'S THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL COVER-UP IN ARIZONA
HISTORY.
I ASK PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE LISTENING, IF YOU WANT
TO HELP US, MAKE SURE WE KEEP
THE SEAT.
THIS IS FOR EVERYBODY, NOT JUST
ARIZONA.
PLEASE GO TO PICK SALLY FOR
SENATE.COM, WE NEED PEOPLE TO
CONTRIBUTE.
GET OUT TO THE POLLS, AND THIS
IS ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: 1-10, HOW IMPORTANT
IS THE TRUMP FACTOR IN ARIZONA?
HE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
JOHN JR. WAS OUT HERE YESTERDAY,
THE PRESIDENT WAS HERE A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, I'M WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH HIM ON SO MANY